تحدث فيها عن كثير من الامور لكن تناول
ايضا ما حدث في ضاحيه لبنان الجنوبيه يوم
امس من اغتيال نائب رئيس المكتب السياسي
لحركه حماس صالح العاروري وقال انها جريمه
لن تمر دون عقاب للوقوف على اهم ما جاء في
هذه الكلمه ينضم الينا من بلده رميش
جنوبيه لبنان مدير مكتب الجزيره مازن
ابراهيم مازن قضايا اذا كثيره تناولتها
هذه الكلمه ابرز ما جاء
فيها
في الواقع زين العابدين من كان يبحث عن
اجابه شافيه تتعلق بكيفيه تعامل حزب الله
ورد حزب الله على عمليه الاغتيال التي
حصلت بالامس في ضاحيه بيروت الجنوبيه فانه
لم يجد الكثير مما يمكن الركون اليه كي
يفهم كيف سيتعامل حزب الله في المرحله
المقبله مع عمليه الاغتيال التي طالت عمق
الضاحيه الجنوبيه وادت الى استشهاد صالح
العاروري عمليا الامين العام لحزب الله
كرر بجمله واحده مقتضبه ما ما ورد على في
بيان حزب الله بالامس بان هذه الجريمه لن
تكون دون عقاب التفاصيل كيف اين لماذا لم
تياتي على ذكرها الامين العام لحزب الله
في هذا البيان الذي كان في هذا الخطاب
الذي كان طويلا وكان هنالك مقدمه من خلال
تلك المقدمه وصل الى الخلاصه بعينها
المقدمه كانت تقول بان هنالك اتفاق بين من
يوصفون باعضاء محور المقاومه على البعد
الاست استراتيجي لكيفيه التعامل مع
اسرائيل ولكن هنالك مصالح وطنيه لكل طرف
ينبغي مراعاتها في الخلاصه عندما وصل الى
الخلاصه تحدث عن ان ما حصل على مستوى
لبنان كان هنالك كسر القواعد من قبل
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وبالتالي المقاومه
الان معنيه بالرد على ما حصل ولكنه لم
يوضح كيف واين ومتى وما هو التكتيك الذي
سيعتمد حزبه في الرد على اغتيال صالح
العاروري هذا من من جهه ومن جهه ثانيه
اعتبر بان اي تقدم اسرائيلي اكثر في في
هذه الاعتداءات والذهاب باتجاه شن حرب على
لبنان فان تحديدا في هذه النقطه لن تعود
مراعاه المصالح الوطنيه تقوم على الانكفاء
او عدم شن حرب في مواجهه اسرائيل ولكنه
اعتبر بان مقتضيات المصالح الوطنيه وفق
توصيفه ستؤدي الى استخدام المقاومه وحزب
الله لكامل قوتها في مواجهه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لذلك انطلاقا من هذه النقطه
تحديدا يمكن الحديث عن مستويين المستوى
الاول يتعلق بعمليه الاغتيال بعينها التي
حصلت بالامس والتي وصفها نصر الله بانها
غير مسبوقه منذ 2006 وفصل فيها بانها لها
دلاله كبيره على مستويين مستوى من وصلت
اليه في الاغتيال على المستوى القيادي من
حركه حماس والمستوى الثاني يرتبط بالاصابه
في عمق الضاحيه الجنوبيه وتوجيه الاستهداف
في عمق هذه الضاحيه الجنوبيه هذا من جهه
من جهه ثانيه هو اعتبر بان كل ما يقوم به
حزبه على طول الخط الجنوبي للبنان على طول
خط الجبهه هنا في جنوب لبنان انه حاله دون
ان تقوم